pick up your phone and scroll and what
you see when you pick up your phone is
obviously everybody's highlight reel
right and I know that that's like so
typical everyone calls it the Highlight
re but it truly is because social media
is a beautiful place to Showcase all the
great things you're doing that's what
it's for and that's amazing you should
showcase all the great things in your
business you should showcase all the
great things that are happening in your
life but what's not happening is people
aren't necessarily going on and talking
about the real stuff that's happening
behind the scenes so it's really easy to
think that you are so alone in whatever
mess is going on because you're
scrolling and you're seeing all the
these fabulous things all these filtered
images all of these maybe maybe fake
vacations maybe fake private jet
situations maybe fake rented cars all of
this stuff and it's coming at us and
that's what we're looking at and that's
what we're surrounded with all the time
and so subconsciously we start to build
this belief that whatever is going on in
our life just isn't good enough because
it doesn't look like that but we have to
remember that that's not real and so I
see a lot of people that come to me a
lot of our clients a lot of people that
DM me they're like Jen like I I I've
been doing the thing that I thought I
needed to do in order to to Be Perfect
online because I'm following all these
people and I'm seeing what they're doing
but I'm just feeling like it's not me
and it's so hard to keep up with and I'm
like what would happen if you just
allowed yourself to take down the
filter to just take a deep breath and
understand and know that the thing that
is the messiest about you the thing that
is the most human about you is probably
going to be the thing that a helps the
most people and B attracts the most
people and I learned that actually
recently so I never used to really okay
with being on camera with like no makeup
on that was always something even when I
started building my brand as like what I
like to call like real genen like not
heavy metal gen that was going on before
but like being me I still had this like
filter up this was before I wrote the
book and everything and I felt that I
wasn't being completely authentic uh a
really good friend of mine who actually
just passed away Jesse Lee uh and I want
to mention her name always when I tell
the story because she gave me this
advice we were in a mastermind together
and we were sitting uh like at this
dinner and she was like you know what
you should do you should really go live
on Instagram with no makeup on and put
your makeup on while you go live and I'm
like that's a terrible idea I would
never do that are you crazy cuz that
felt scary and vulnerable and no way in
hell would I do that and I when the
morning that I woke up and thought that
I was going to write a book I was like
you know I need to allow myself to be
seen and fully connect with people
otherwise no one's going to want to buy
a book from me no one's going to want to
learn how to be seen from me no one's
going to want to learn from me if they
just think that everything in my life is
perfect tomorrow morning I'm I'm going
to go live like what Jesse Lee said and
I'm going to put my makeup on and if no
one shows up it's okay I don't care I'm
just going to go go on there and see
what happens so I did it and it was
scary and not a lot of people showed up
and it wasn't that much fun and I wasn't
very good however I made a commitment to
myself and I kept doing it and now I do
this every single day Monday through
Friday I go live I put my makeup on and
I answer questions and I talk to people
this has been the best content strategy
that I ever implemented in my business
ever to this day wow ever it's the best
lead generator it's the best people are
are connecting with each other I've
created community on this Instagram live
they're all going out to dinner with
each other they're all coming to my
event together they're all they're all
like part of this group they've all
become part of my street team for my
book they all buy whatever it is I'm
selling whether that's a free thing or
or a paid thing because we get ready
together every morning and because I'm
allowing myself to be real so maybe I've
got a highlight re when you look at my
page and that's great because I'm
promoting myself but there's this time
in the morning that's for 1 hour when
I've got no makeup on my face and I'm
totally messy and vulnerable and I'm
practicing answering people's questions
I'm practicing speaking I'm actually
telling stories and talking and
answering questions and connecting that
I'm real and I'm telling them this is
what's going on today it's a I've got my
three dogs barking in the background
like my husband's running back like
we're we're yelling at each other all
this stuff is happening I'm putting
makeup on my face I've got an eyelash in
my hand and my hair is sticking up and
I'm putting in my hair extensions and
that not only helped my algorithm which
you could probably talk about in a big
way like I'm sure going live really does
help your algorithm and I got a lot more
engagement but it also created a deep
connection ction with my customer my
avatar my my dream audience member what
would you say to somebody who says okay
so maybe I should put myself out there
in a raw format be vulnerable make up
off share about maybe my past or
something I'm going through that an
eating disorder going through
addiction but what if somebody comes out
like it's so common in Internet comments
and is cruel or what if it doesn't work
and what if wow I hear you say that I
don't know if I want to try that
tomorrow morning what message would you
have for me yeah so the internet trolls
that's the first thing we'll talk about
because that's going to happen when when
you start to be seen and you start to
put yourself out there not everybody's
going to understand it not everybody's
going to like it but what I remember or
try to remind myself of whenever I
experience that is number one first of
all it doesn't feel good okay so I'm not
going to sit here and be like just
delete and block and it's okay cuz it's
not it sucks everyone wants to be liked
nobody wants to get Negative feed
feedback or comments on their posts but
my therapist always asks me her famous
question for me all the time is what do
you want your relationship with that to
be because we get to choose what our
perspective of that is we don't get to
choose like that it hurts and it stings
and like it doesn't feel good and it's
not fun and we don't get to choose if it
happens or not it's going to happen but
what do we want our relationship with it
to be and for me I'm going to understand
that anybody that's commenting on my
comments in a mean way or saying
something negative or saying something
nasty that is to hurt me or is to bring
me down I know that that person must be
in pain or must not be very happy
because I know a lot of happy and
successful people and I know that not
one of them would ever even dare to just
go on the internet and comment
negatively or something mean on
somebody's post so I just think okay I
feel really bad for this person I'm
going to have empathy for this person
and I'm going to understand and know
that this is the thing that I signed up
for that there's going to be people like
this on the internet that unfortunately
are sad and not so happy and they're
going to take it out on me and my
relationship with that is I'm just going
to think empathetically towards them and
send them love in my my mind and uh and
understand to know that my relationship
with this is this is what it is how do I
want to react understand that this is
part of the game and move on and and try
as hard as I possibly can to not let it
affect me in a negative way or not keep
me from showing up because for every
single person that's on there talking
smack there's probably at least 20 30 40
50 other people that really liked that
post that really got a lot out of it and
maybe for some of those people it helped
them in a way that I don't even know
maybe some of the maybe there was
somebody if I posted about something
that was really a big deal for me maybe
the eating disorder that I experienced
uh and I post and talk about that openly
or I talk about it openly in the book
for every person that's like oh I can't
believe her that's gross or whatever or
might say something mean or negative
because it might activate them there
might be a woman out there that's like
wow I feel not alone now in this problem
and she really helped me to be able to
like just flip my mindset around for
this day this one day or just not feel
alone in this today and that's why I do
what I do to help one person every day I
call it that the acronym that I use is
hope I just think about maybe that one
person that's on the other side of the
phone that needs to hear that today and
when I get up and every day if I get
nervous to go online with no makeup on
or share a messy part of my life or
share something that's going on that I'm
really afraid that people are going to
judge me for I think about the one
person that might need to hear that
today and I just Envision talking to
them that's powerful ho o p help one
person every day what a great social
media Vision in a content creator vision
and let's talk about
branding what is a brand H that's a good
question what is a brand I mean there's
probably a bazillion different
definitions for this so I'll give you
what I think it is yeah um for me your
brand is your essence your brand your
brand can change and your brand can
shift and your brand is actually who you
are so I think that people get it wrong
when they think that your brand is like
your colors and your fonts and your you
know this thing that you create uh
because if you create your brand and
it's like this yes all of those pieces
come into the puzzle when you're
starting to build out your website and
all the things that you create on the
side but if you're looking at it in the
2023 and Beyond realm like everybody is
a brand now everybody has a virtual
presence of some kind think about it
even if you're not a business owner or
you're not an entrepreneur or you you
just you don't even have anything that
you want to showcase on the internet if
I was in the dating world and I
connected with somebody on an app on
social media or whatever on an app and I
was going on a date with them if I went
online and had no online presence they
had no brand online what of whatsoever I
wouldn't go out with them cuz I would be
like that's weird like that is weird and
that's scary and that kind of freaks me
out I want to see something everybody
has some Essence online and it's not
what you want to create it to be and I
think we get into trouble when we try to
do that who are you genuinely my brand
is everything that I am it's not just
that I wrote a book it's not just that
I'm a speaker it's not just that I'm a
business owner it's also that I'm a New
Yorker and I've got three dogs and I
like watching baking shows but I don't
bake I love lifting weights like I uh
have a really loud high-pitched voice
sometimes uh I you know there's all
these like things about me and it's just
Jen it's who I am and the cool thing
about that about making that my brand is
that that can evolve and change and grow
as I evolve and change and grow so if I
choose that I am this person I am heavy
metal girl and like that's it and I
build everything around that if I evolve
in change and grow and I have just
solidified my brand as one thing it's
going to be really really hard for me to
live my life authentically and it's
going to get really exhausting so if you
just make your brand who you are and you
allow it to grow and evolve with you and
it just is your essence like I don't
have a PR agency anymore great but
people follow me because I'm genen like
all the things that make me genen not
necessarily what I do then everyone's
going to keep on following because it's
just me and I can keep growing and
evolving and that's my brand if you
enjoy this podcast and are ready for
some deep dive YouTube strategy just go
to think masterclass.com to get access
to my 1H hour on demand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com